joe biden announces violence on all
sides but
never mentions black lives matter or
antifa as the media sing his praises
trump defends kyle rittenhouse and
paintball gun wielding protesters in
portland
and the media demand trump visit with
jacob lake's family i'm ben shapiro this
is the ben shapiro show
[Music]
the ben shapiro show is sponsored by
expressvpn your data is your business
protected at expressvpn.com
ben okay so yesterday joe biden traveled
to pennsylvania not to kenosha wisconsin
because he understood
that the backdrop of burned cities
cities burned by people presumably who
largely support him
would have been kind of bad so instead
he went to pittsburgh he flew out of his
basement to pittsburgh
he spoke for approximately 12 minutes he
got back in his plane
he got back in his basement that was his
schedule yesterday
and in the process of those 12 minutes
he apparently did something great and
phenomenal
he said violence is bad violence is very
very bad guys
now this is really not enough and the
way you know this isn't enough is
because the riots continued in portland
last night but
saying violence is bad is apparently all
that was required of joe biden now
that's kind of weird it's a weird take
because normally if you're going to
denounce violence what you have to do is
denounce the movement that is causing
the violence you have to denounce the
people who are associated
with the violence you can't just come
out and say all violence is bad this
would be called
obfuscating in fact it would be a form
of moral cowardice
to do the routine where there's violence
in america's major cities and then you
just say you know what
i don't like things burning violence is
not good
that is completely useless in fact it is
not only useless it is counterproductive
when you then go ahead and grant
credence to all of the arguments of the
people who are trying to literally burn
buildings
and that's exactly what joe biden did
but the media have set up a bar so low
for joe biden so
unbelievably low for joe biden that it
would be nearly impossible for him
not to clear the bar unless you were
actually dead
and i joke about joe biden being dead
and the truth is he's only about half
dead
right he's he's only mostly dead i've
seen worse
i've seen wars he's only mostly dead so
all joe biden really had to do according
to the media we just come out and be
like riding is bad and looting is bad
and that's it
that's it and stay awake for 12 minutes
and take no questions and turn around
and go back to
his basement in delaware and that's
precisely what joe biden did and the
media celebrated what an act of heroism
where is trump doing the same thing why
can't trump say that violence
and looting are bad okay trump has said
that violence and looting are bad you
know what else trump has done
he has offered federal force to every
major american city to help quell this
stuff
and democrats all over the united states
have turned down the federal
aid that president trump has offered and
then claimed that this is all trump's
fault
so this is really not about president
trump these are not trump supporters in
the major
cities who are burning and rioting and
looting and so far the only evidence we
have
of somebody who is a trump supporter
killing anybody it probably looks like
self-defense which is that kyle
rittenhouse case which we'll get to in
just a little while
yet the media tweeted joe biden's
statement yesterday as a unifying
presidential statement
and this is very reminiscent of the
treatment that the media used to give
barack obama who would make unbelievably
divisive statements
on issues ranging from race to riots and
then they would say well didn't he just
bring the country together
see obama had a gift of speaking
incredibly vaguely such that you could
project
your feelings onto him and joe biden is
a great front man
for exactly the same thing because joe
biden as you'll see in the speech that
he gave yesterday
he said the quiet part out loud he said
do i look like a radical and the answer
is no he doesn't look like a radical
in fact he looks like the front man for
a radical group joe biden looks
like the guy they put out front who
doesn't look radical specifically
so they can then make him his meat
puppet their meat puppet and basically
just manipulate him however
they damn well please and the way you
can tell they are doing this is again
an act of moral courage would be to say
antifa
is evil and they are committing acts of
evil an act of moral courage would be to
say
that the black lives matter movement has
rioters and looters associated with it
who are evil right that would have been
the act of moral courage and in fact
exactly that sort of moral courage was
demanded of president trump quite
rightly with regard to charlottesville
as i mentioned yesterday
but it's never demanded of joe biden in
fact if you listen to joe biden's little
address yesterday
i did a word account on it joe biden
name-checked armed militias
he name-checked armed militias or
right-wing militias three times
he he did not mention antifa or blm
he name checked white nationalist once
and white supremacist ones if you listen
to his speech yesterday
what you would have gathered from it if
you'd come from mars and just landed in
the middle of this political cycle
you'd have gathered that armed white
bands of people
who were right-wing were gathering in
america's major cities and rioting and
looting and robbing and burning
that's what you would have gathered from
the speech because not once did he name
check the actual groups that were
committing these acts of violence now
i've been informed by the left that
silence
is violence that if you don't if you
don't repeat the messages they want you
to repeat you're very bad i've also been
informed by the left it's very important
to say their names
right and so we have said the names of
people on this program and we've
reviewed the cases of people on this
program
who are shot by police and we've talked
about the legal
situations regarding each one of these
people we've talked about the
george floyd situation and whether that
actually constitutes a second degree
murder or whether it just
constitutes excessive force we've talked
about the jacob blake case we've talked
about the brianna taylor
case we've talked about the richard
brooks case those are all names we've
said all of them here on the show
well if you're going to do say their
names so that we can
talk about the real issues at play in
america then you must you must
say the names of the groups that are
actually committing the violence joe
biden didn't do that
in fact joe biden played a rather nasty
little trick and the media were
completely complicit
the gap between what biden should have
said and what biden did say was
completely filled by the media
the media are now in the business of
backfilling whatever they think
biden should say by pretending he said
it so let's go through what joe biden
actually said because this was
apparently an earth-shatteringly good
speech a very very powerful
powerful speech that basically fulfilled
all of joe biden's obligations
we're going to go through in detail in a
way that the media will not today we're
going to go through joe biden's speech
and we're gonna talk about what he
actually said and what he should have
said and what he didn't say and what he
didn't say is of course the most
important part
of this particular formula so biden
shows up
in pittsburgh pennsylvania against a
backdrop of american flags looking
not great i mean as we'll see joe biden
kind of stumbled and bumbled his way
through this one and there's a reason
that there's talk of him not debating
president trump the man
has clearly declined which is a separate
issue from the fact that he's a moral
coward
but he began his speech by suggesting
that president trump is the one who is
rooting for the riots
which again is a weird take considering
that it is mayor ted wheeler a democrat
in portland who has allowed riots to
continue unabated for three straight
months
that it was seattle that allowed a
full-on communist
terror state to be set up in the middle
of their city that it's chicago
that had to raise the bridges because
the chicago loop was being ransacked
there was washington dc where the
suburbs were actually being
ransacked in the middle of the blm
protest slash riots and looting that it
was new york city where fifth avenue was
being attacked
led by bill de blasio none of these
places tend to be particularly trump
friendly
nor are the people who are rioting and
looting doing so at the behest of
president trump
those people hate president trump yet
here was joe biden blaming trump for
everything bad that happens again this
was the theme of the dnc
joe biden and the democrats continue to
try and make the election referendum on
donald trump's character it's difficult
to make it a referendum on donald
trump's character when your party has
poo poo to antifa
i'm old enough to remember because i'm
more again than three months old
when republicans and democrats held a
hearing in the senate
and antifa was mentioned repeatedly and
democrats literally refused to
acknowledge that antifa existed
anyway here was joe biden trying to
blame trump for this yesterday in
pittsburgh
the incumbent president is incapable of
telling us the truth
and capable of facing the facts and
incapable of healing
he doesn't want to shed light he wants
to generate heat
and he's stroking violence in our cities
oh he's the one who's first of all
stroking violence
stoking violence you i understand that
everything looks like stroking to joe
biden
particularly when he is in any sort of
close contact with a woman
who uh who is apparently not related to
him but
no he's not stroking violence in the
city's joe that would be the democrats
who continue
to maintain lack of order in their
cities you know what stops disorder
order
and you know what democrats have not
provided that okay so then here is the
part
where everybody was like gaga over joe
biden what what what courage
okay so remember the narrative here the
narrative according to joe biden and
you'll see it played throughout the
speech
is that donald trump is responsible for
the writing and the looting that police
brutality
is responsible for the rioting and the
looting the white nationalists and armed
right-wing militias are responsible
for the rioting and the looting it is
not in fact
radical racial activists who are going
around burning and looting
it is not in fact radical communists in
anarchists like members of antifa
it is just those three forces those are
the only ones that are bad the only ones
who are bad here
are trump the quote unquote armed right
with militias
and the police those are the only three
groups that are bad so here he was going
after the cops
and now we have to stand against
violence
and every former takes violence we've
seen again
and again and again of unwarranted
police shooting
excessive force seven bullets in the
back of jacob blake
nean the neck of george floyd killing a
brianna taylor in her own apartment
violence of extremists and opportunist
right-wing militias this is insane okay
this is an insane statement and it's an
act again of moral cowardice we have to
stand against violence in every form it
takes and where does he begin
he begins with the cops the cops are the
bad guys
again this is supposed to be the
unifying speech this is the guy who's
going to bring the country together he
begins
with the idea that the biggest problem
in america is police violence
excessive force and then the number one
case he cites is the case of jacob blake
which is a nuts okay again the case of
jacob blake
is a case where a man had an open
warrant for sexual assault and domestic
abuse
the only reason the cops were there is
because a prior victim of sexual assault
by jacob blake called the cops because
that morning according to the new york
post
he raped her again he went into her room
where she was sleeping with her kid and
shoved his fingers up her
okay this is according to her allegation
the cops showed up they tried to arrest
him
he refused to be arrested they tried to
tase him he wouldn't stay on the ground
he walked around the side of the car he
reached into his car there was a knife
on the floorboards of the driver's side
of his car and they shot him and this is
the number one case
of violence in every form it takes
according to joe biden and this is a
great unifying speech
this is a great unifying speech he cites
george floyd
as as one of these cases of the violence
that is completely unnecessary
you can make the case on george floyd
that it was excessive force
and in fact prosecutors will make that
case the case on second degree murder
is a lot less certain especially because
there are separate autopsies concluding
that he died because there's an
enormous amount of fentanyl in his
system enough to kill a horse the
killing of brianna taylor
may be a tragedy but it was not in fact
a
a law violation they had a justly taken
no knock warrant on her apartment
there's a man in the apartment who shot
at the cops and in the crossfire brianna
taylor
was killed there's now very solid
evidence that has been put forth that
bri
that linked brianna taylor with drug
trafficking okay that does not mean
that she should have died but to pretend
that
what happened there was a result of
police malice
and then who else does he cite violence
of extremists and opportunists what kind
of extremism what kind of opportunist
joe
who are you talking about there i have
no idea what that means who are the
extremists who are the opportunists and
then right-wing militias
so just to again get this straight joe
biden is condemning violence from all
sides except for the people
who he thinks are part of his coalition
antifa and blm
that is what he is condemning yesterday
we'll continue with this this was the
constant theme and again the media just
filled in the gap for him the media like
oh well now he's condemned all violence
where's trump condemning all the
violence he didn't condemn all violence
he condemned violence from people that
he doesn't like and he completely
ignored the vast bulk of violence that's
been happening in the united states
since may
he ignored it and instead decided to
cast that as a
a right-wing problem which is the
highest form of gaslighting i've seen in
politics in quite some time we've seen a
lot of gaslighting this year we'll get
some more of this in just one second
first
let's talk about how frustrating it is
to pay for something then find out that
you could have gotten a much better deal
elsewhere this happens pretty much every
time you look at that cell phone bill
you're like wow
why is this costing me like hundreds of
dollars a month
i'll tell you why because you're paying
for the marketing efforts by those phone
companies and not only that
you're also paying for unlimited data
that you probably aren't using well
think of all the money you automatically
give away with this now if you've got a
t or verizon or t-mobile they'll all
want to charge you for data and perks
that you'll never use and this is why
you need pure talk usa
pure talk gives you the exact same
coverage same tower same bars it costs
you half
no contract no excessive fees right now
enjoy unlimited talk text two gigs of
data
all for just 20 bucks a month the
average person is saving 400
a year on their wireless bill so grab
your mobile phone dial pound 250
say ben shapiro when you do you'll save
250 bucks off any iphone
including the new iphone se again that
is pound two five zero
say keyword bennett shapiro pure talk
usa simply smarter wireless again
i'll pound 250 say keyword ben shapiro
make the magic happen save money on your
cell phone bill and get the exact same
service again
pure talk usa pound two five zero say
keyword ben
shapiro to get started okay joe biden
continued
along these lines and this is the part
and now
he's really getting going here guys
because he says rioting and looting are
bad
now it is true that 13 members of his
campaign staff
literally pay to bail rioters and
looters out of jail in minneapolis
it is true that his vice presidential
his vice presidential candidate kamala
harris
joined that group and tried to have
these people bailed out of jail
it is also true that the that members of
the democratic party have routinely
pretended that rioting and looting are
not happening and that if they are
happening they are the natural outgrowth
of legitimate anger that's the ayana
presley position
but apparently joe biden said enough
yesterday because he says
i know again the moral the moral bar is
so low here that all he had to say
according to the media was
i don't like when people break into
businesses and burn stuff here was joe
biden saying he doesn't like it when
people break into businesses and burn
stuff
and to derail any hope and support for
progress
the senseless violence of looting and
burning and destruction of property
i want to make it absolutely clear
something very clear about all of this
rioting is not protesting looting is not
protesting
setting fires is not protesting
none of this is protesting it's
lawlessness
plain and simple and those who do it
should be prosecuted violence will not
bring
change it will only bring destruction
it's wrong in every way it divides
instead of unites
destroys businesses only hurts the
working families
that serve the community it makes things
worse across the board not better
now i'm happy that he's saying that um
crimes should be prosecuted because it
turns out that
democratic da's all across the united
states democratic
states attorneys all across the united
states have decided to not prosecute
people who have involved themselves in
rioting and looting
and violence in fact they've decided to
let them out of jail
in fact the man who shot the antifa
member who allegedly shot
a trump supporter to death in portland
the other day was arrested on june 5th
and then he was immediately released
without any charges being filed against
him despite a gun charge against him
so i'm glad that joe biden has decided
to go back to being tough on crime joe
biden from 1994 oh wait he's not going
to do any of that
okay then of course joe biden moves on
to his real point which is that it's
donald's trump fault
it's donald trump's fault now in here is
the implicit threat the implicit threat
here is that if donald trump is
reelected things are going to get worse
elect me
and magically all of this will disappear
now it probably isn't true because the
truth is
i don't think that joe biden is actually
in control of the rioters and looters as
demonstrated by the fact that the
writing and looting continued last night
in portland as demonstrated by the fact
that we had major riots in the united
states in ferguson
in baltimore in milwaukee while joe
biden was vice president of the united
states
so this magical notion that joe biden is
going to heal all divides and
and patch over the american soul is sure
crap i mean it's just not true
at all but the threat is there we'll get
to joe biden's tacit threat
the tacit threat to the united states
which is if you keep electing people we
don't like
then people that i like are going to
keep burning things we'll get to that in
a second first
let us talk about how important it is to
protect your online data i mean you know
you know there are lots of people who
are out there to hack you there's all
sorts of malware that is out there to
make your life miserable there's
ransomware that is designed to lock up
files that you need unless you pay
somebody
exorbitant amounts of money a lot of
evil folks out there
who want to invade your data and this is
why you need pcmatic pcmatic is a
next-generation anti-virus designed to
stop modern threats like ransomware
independent testing from av test just
named pcmatic a top performer in the
cyber security industry giving it the
best performance award for 2019.
only pcmatic has american research
development and support pcmatic's
competition is foreign made often in
countries where the malware originates
in
the first place pcmatic will block
annoying and malicious ads for
hassle-free web browsing
as well and make your computer faster
and more reliable even after years
of use and what's best it doesn't cost
you very much at all pcmatic is just 50
bucks for five devices
for one year with a full 30-day
money-back guarantee and if you act
right now pcmatic has offered my
listeners a free month of security
protection with the purchase of an
annual license
protecting your information that's not
something you should put off because you
feel like you should have bought it two
days after somebody hacks you to access
this offer go to pcmatic.com
ben again get world-class security that
keeps your computer running great go to
pcmatic.com
that's pcmatic.com ben okay then
joe biden continues and of course he
blames donald trump and the implicit
threat here is if you keep electing
donald trump the violence will continue
but if you elect me magically things
will go away
well weird weird so either he's in
control of the riders or he's not in
control of the rioters but
here was joe biden making the tacit
threat fires are burning and we have a
president who fans the flames
rather than fighting the flames but
we must not burn we have to build
this president long ago forfeited any
moral leadership in this country
he can't stop the violence because for
years he's fomented it
you know he may believe mouthing the
words law and order makes him strong
but his failure to call on his own
supporters to stop
acting as an armed militia in this
country shows how
weak he is does anyone believe there'll
be less violence in america
if donald trump is reelected in other
words if you're like me
the violence will stop by the way it is
amazing to know amazing this entire
speech
at no point does joe biden say anyone
who supports me who's out there riding
and looting needs to stop right now
i'm talking to i may support the agenda
of blm but if you are associated with
blm and you're rioting and you're
looting
stop that right now you're not doing
good work antifa
if you're out there right now listening
to sound of my voice and i'm joe biden
and you think that you're helping me out
you're not stop it right he won't say
any of that stuff because he
specifically will not call out anybody
on his own side of the aisle he won't
you think those people are trump
supporters
so while he's saying that armed militias
are being emboldened by president
trump it's not the armed militias that
are causing the violence in america's
major cities this has been going on for
months on end months on end
this is i mean this was a seriously
despicable speech it really was
and the fact that everybody is trying to
treat it as though it was a monumental
statement of moral courage
just demonstrates their own biases
because if donald trump gave the same
exact speech
if he gave the same exact speech right
in reverse
it would be charlottesville and this
would be the reason that joe biden
decided to run
okay so here is joe biden saying talking
about the crises that are facing the
united states again you may notice
one crisis facing the united states that
he refuses to call out he's gonna name
you a bunch of crises
and again he's gonna name check the
white nationalists who again were not
responsible for like
the white nationalists they're
responsible for a lot of bad things
they're evil
they don't like people like me with my
funny little hat and my judaism and
everything
okay they've literally targeted me but
here's joe biden blaming the white
nationalist for
a bunch of antifa members and black
lives matter members
running around burning things and
attacking police officers and generally
making life unlivable in in major swaths
of american cities
we need justice in america we need
safety in america
we're facing multiple crises crisis
under donald trump have kept multiplying
coveted economic devastation
unwarranted police violence emboldened
white nationalists
a reckoning on race declining faith and
the birth
and the of the right american future
this is an incredible litany that he
puts out there again
the litany of issues facing the united
states this is a speech about violence
and looting and writing
here are the things that he names kovid
which is not trump's fault
economic devastation which is a direct
result of covet and of
insane democratic lockdowns that
continue in states like new york and new
jersey where there's no uptick
and an extraordinarily low rate of
transmission unwarranted police violence
or he name checks that first it's about
the cops the cops are bad guys
white nationalists okay what do they
have to do with anything going on in
america's major cities
again even the cases where you've got
the militia members who are showing up
in these cities
patriot prayer is not a white
nationalist group kyle rittenhouse who's
not a white nationalist
a reckoning on race i love the stop
pedaling there it's a reckoning what
we're watching are reckoning
so when blm burns cities that's a
reckoning guys
it's a reckoning but don't worry this
was again i've been told
a statement of moral courage and then
joe biden says the quiet part out loud
he says listen i'm the soft face of the
radicals behind me
he says look at me look at me i'm not
i'm not radical
i'm not a socialist do i look like
somebody who's in favor of rights
no you don't joe you look like a corpse
you know
you look like the dead front you look
like el said you look like a dead man
propped onto a horse so the radicals
behind you can charge forward to victory
that's what you look like that is what
joe biden looks like that's why he's
there
okay joe biden is not there maybe he's
there because there are a lot of
moderate democrats who didn't want those
people running the show
but in effect what joe biden is is a
front man for that he proved that by
selecting as his running mate kamal
harris who again
was explicitly asking for rioters and
looters to be bailed out of prison
in minnesota here is joe biden saying
don't i make like a nice facade for all
the radicalism don't i
you know me you know my heart
you know my story my family story ask
yourself
do i look like a radical socialist with
a soft spot for rioters
really i want a safe america
safe from covert safe from crime and
looting
safe from racially motivated violence
safe from bad cops
let me be crystal clear safe from four
more years of donald trump
okay again that is amazing that right
now you're watching riots in the cities
and you're like oh yeah that
will keep you safe from trump marauding
orange bad man
okay in a second we'll get to more of
the this is donald trump's fault
because this is a bizarre case like a
really bizarre case remember the people
who are riding in these cities
are all people who are going to go vote
for biden if they vote no not one of
those people is a trump supporter not
one
he'll get some more of this in just one
second first let us talk about the fact
that
as we slowly adjust to what's happening
in the united states it's now been
months and months and months and months
one of the things you probably don't
want to be doing is heading on over
to the post office this is why you
should be using stamps.com in fact
thousands of small business owners have
discovered the benefits of stamps.com
in recent months i've been using
stamps.com for years so it came as no
shock to me nor as as an additional
benefit when
everything that's been happening started
happening i already knew but i've been
able to inform you for a long time that
stamps.com is a better way
of sending your mail with stamps.com you
can print posted john demand and avoid
going to the post office and you'll save
money with discounted rates you can't
even get at the post office
stamps.com also offers ups services with
discounts up to 62
no residential surcharges again here at
dailywear we've been saving our time and
money since 2017.
stamps.com brings all the mailing and
shipping services you might need
directly to your computer
you can use your computer to print
official us postage 24 7 for any letter
any package any class of mail anywhere
you want to send it
so once your mail is ready you just
leave it for the mail carrier and they
pick it up and you get great discounts
too with stamps.com
five cents off every single stamp up to
62 off usps
and ups shipping rates right now my
listeners get an amazing offer four week
trial
plus free postage and a digital scale no
long-term commitment
that is a solid deal just head on over
to stamps.com click on the microphone at
the top of the homepage and type in
shapiro that is stamps.com
and enter shapiro at the top of the
homepage for the special deal
alrighty so joe biden continues and he
suggests
that this is all about donald trump it's
all about trump right orange mad bad
so he says that donald trump is seeing a
political lifeline here so he is just
going to engage in the
tried and true media tactic of
republicans pounds so democrats do
something terrible
and the problem is that republicans are
pouncing on the democrats doing
something terrible which means that it's
really the republicans fault
here is slow old joe i look at this
violence when i see
lives and communities and the dreams of
small businesses being destroyed
and the opportunity for real progress on
issues of race and police reform
and justice being put to the test
donald trump looks at this violence and
he sees
a political lifeline okay so it's all
about trump and his political lifeline
and then he says the violence that we
are seeing is in donald trump's america
so how exactly does joe biden make the
case
that violence in entirely blue cities
with governors who are explicitly
rejecting federal help from donald trump
that that is donald trump's fault it's
donald trump's america
okay by that measure ferguson baltimore
milwaukee like everything that happens
in the united states that's bad
falls to the presidents of the united
states which is really not how any of
this works we do have a federalist
system and local governance tends to
matter
an awful lot so what exactly is the
argument that joe biden is really making
the argument that joe biden is really
making is that if donald trump would
just surrender to blm
if donald trump would just do their
agenda items this would all stop
okay now this is where the radicalism
really comes out so he won't name check
blm he won't name check antifa
his real case is that if donald trump
would be
more forthcoming to the demands of blm
they would stop
if donald trump would cower before blm
if he would kneel when they want him to
kneel
if you would say the slogans they want
him to say then they would stop no never
mind that donald trump
actually pursued and put into law
criminal justice reform
precisely the opposite of the program
that joe biden pushed in 1994.
i forget that donald trump has pardoned
a variety of people including alice
johnson
right forget all of that what joe biden
really wants is for trump to pledge
fealty to blm
and the idea here from the democrats
because this has always been an inside
outside game you have rioters in the
streets
and then you have democratic mayors and
politicians this is going on for
generations who have said
if we just cave to the demands of the
rioters then all of this will stop
here is joe biden making that explicit
if donald trump would just cave to the
demands of blm who by the way
have not made any credible demands then
all of this would stop
so this is again the threat of violent
it's just joe biden using blm and antifa
as the threat of violence
i find it fascinating quote you won't be
safe in
joe biden's america and what's their
proof
the violence we're seeing and donald
trumps america
donald trump adds fuel to every fire
because he refuses to even acknowledge
that there is a racial justice problem
in america because he won't stand up to
any form of violence
he's got no problem with right-wing
militia white supremacists and
vigilantes with assault weapons
often better armed than the police often
in the middle of the violence
at the protesters and aiming it there
okay now
that is a subtle reference to kyle
rittenhouse who was there to provide
medical aid and protect private property
and then somehow ended up separated off
from the main group and by video
evidence
shot three people in self-defense okay
that is what the video evidence tends to
show there's a full new york times
rundown
of the play-by-play on that but
apparently written house is the bad guy
this is all about right with militias
it's all about donald trump but
buried in there is the line that matters
most in this whole thing
he says that donald trump adds fuel to
every fighter because he to every fire
because he refuses to even acknowledge
there's a racial justice problem in
america in other words if you don't
speak
and believe if you don't say that the
police are systemically racist
then that is the problem in fact if you
just repeated all of our favorite
slogans then all this would go away
right the violence would stop now again
not true barack obama repeated those
slogans and it didn't seem to matter one
damn iota in ferguson or baltimore
milwaukee but
this is the democratic case we will do
the work of the agitators
and then all of this will go away hey
joe biden continued
and he said that if you were president
the country would be safer why
why because he would repeat the slogans
that blm wants him to repeat because he
would
meld the platitudes that are false about
the systemic racism of the united states
and the evils of law enforcement again
this is
this is if you want to be blackmailed
vote for joe biden
where you must say repeat kneel
or the riots come for you here's joe
biden again
frankly i believe if i were president
today
the country would be safer and we've
seen a lot less violence and here's why
i have said we must address the issue of
racial injustice
i've personally spoken to george floyd's
family
in the jacob blake's family i know their
pain
and so do you i know the justice they
seek and so do you
they've told us none of this violence
respects or honors
george or jacob i believe we can bring
these
these the these folks fighting for
racial justice to the table okay so the
characterization
of the people riding and looting is that
they are fighting for racial justice
that is literally the characterization
you just used
who the hell is he talking about bring
them to the table that's usually
language reserved for people who are
quote unquote
not at the table in other words doing
violence outside the system
he says that if you just say the police
are bad that if you quote unquote
address the issue of racial injustice
and he uses as case in point jacob blake
again a man who had just allegedly raped
a woman
when the police were called on him and
then was reaching for a knife on the
floorboards of his car by available
evidence when he was shot
that if you just cater to the needs and
whims of that particular movement
then all of this goes away because those
folks will come back to the table
so that is what joe biden is pledging he
is pledging fuel to you to blm
right and to the radicals of blm not
even the broader kind of movement of
people
who may be marching in good faith
believing that if they mouth slogans
they will make the world a better place
and joe biden then continued and he said
more cops have died from cover than have
been killed on patrol so he's trying to
downplay the danger to police officers
that's happening in the united states
right now somebody who routinely speaks
to police officers across the country
this is ridiculous this is ridiculous
and insane police officers are walking
off the job
they're getting ready to retire they're
getting ready to quit they're getting
ready to move out of major american
cities
because they are scared to death that if
they defend themselves that if they
defend the public
they're going to be brought up on
charges by people like joe biden
okay my favorite is is his suggestion
that the great damage to the police
is covid listen to the staff that he
signs i mean this this is just plain
it's plain dishonesty with stats here
here's joe biden more cops
have died from cove this year than have
been killed on patrol
nearly one in six small businesses
closed in this country today
do you really feel safer under trump
okay that's an amazing statement when he
says
that more cops have died from covet than
have been killed on patrol
ask a cop are they more afraid of coping
or are they more afraid of being on
patrol right now
that's there's no question what the
answer is everybody knows the answer to
that question by the way if we're going
to do that routine
more people have died from covet then
okay more people have died from covet
then have been killed unarmed by the
police by a factor of oh
about ten thousand literally ten
thousand
but apparently this is a moment
requiring racial reckoning in the united
states according to joe biden joe biden
wrapped up this politically
motivated bleep show by then suggesting
at the very end he's like oh yeah by the
way i'm in pennsylvania i'm not banning
fracking
i'm not going to it was this weird
bizarre moment where in
a speech about bringing the country
together and
supposed racial unity and ending
violence and looting he's like i know by
the way i'm in pennsylvania and i like
fracking now
there's joe biden and this is just so
nakedly partisan and political it's
unbelievable
i'm not banning frackie let me say that
again
i am not banning frackie no matter how
many times
donald trump lies about me
this future the future that's what this
is all about
okay he's not he's not banning fracking
okay just quick note um
he has said before that he would uh ban
fracking here he was
it's just a couple months ago in new
hampshire what about say stopping
fracking and stopping
no no yes yes yes no new pipelines he
has said in open debate that he wants to
end fossil fuel reliance which
involves fracking he has said that he
wants to end permits for new fracking
but don't worry he's not going to ban
friends he's not going to affect any of
the jobs in pennsylvania
now here's the reality here joe biden is
a as i've said he is a facade for a much
more radical movement everybody knows it
and he's not much of a facade at this
point because he's falling apart there's
a reason that he showed up and he gave a
speech and then he ran away before
anybody could ask him a single question
and by the way i have no doubt that no
journalist will ask him to actually by
name condemn antifa
or blm in the texases or even the
excesses of blm let alone blm is a
movement but
the reason that joe biden is arriving
and doing these little speeches and then
running away before the press can ask
him a question is because he is not
he is not with it here was a piece of
his speech yesterday again he was on
script right he's reading from
teleprompter
and here was joe biden almost falling
off the stage
covert has taken this year just since
the outbreak
has taken more than 100 years
look here's the lives it's just
it's it means think about it more lives
this year than any other year
for the past hundred years what
he's not even speaking english anymore
he's just speaking senility apparently
but don't worry if you mention this by
the way if you mention that joe biden
has diminished obviously in terms of his
faculties which is clearly
and obviously true if you mention that
at all and jamelle bowie the poor man's
tone of his coats
will suggest that uh you're engaged in a
conspiracy theory
because you're using your eyeballs stop
that in a second we're gonna get to
president trump and his response to all
of this
and it is imperfect but far closer to
right then
than uh joe biden's ridiculous response
that was defeated by the media yesterday
we'll get to more of this in a second
first
let's talk about how hard it is to do
hiring on your own it is really
difficult you get like enormous numbers
of resumes a lot of them are just bad
it's very difficult to filter them out
or to keep them straight just got a
bunch of papers on your desk how do you
figure out who to hire and who not to
hire and how do you make sure that
you're getting
the best cross-section of people to hire
well this is why you need ziprecruiter
zip recruiter will send your job to over
100 of the web's leading job sites but
they don't stop there
with their powerful matching technology
ziprecruiter will scan thousands of
resumes to find people with the right
experience and then actively invite them
to apply to your job zip recruiter makes
hiring efficient and effective
with features like screening questions
to filter candidates and an
all-in-one dashboard where you can
review and rate your candidates in fact
zip recruiter is so effective that four
out of five employers who post unzip
recruiter get a quality candidate within
the very first day like let's say that
you have an employee
who not only once dated a person who
trained wolves
but then for no reason at all after that
person demonstrated full scale that they
were not particularly with it
decided to maybe even get back together
with that person you might judge you
might judge that person would you not
you might think would i hire that person
should that person continue to draw a
paycheck i mean this person clearly
lacks common sense
i mean i'm not going to name names like
nick but if you were to think that that
person needed to be replaced the place
that you would go is zip recruiter dot
com slash
daily wire that is ziprecruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e
slip recruiter dot com slash daily wires
it requires indeed the smartest
way to hire all right we're gonna get to
more
on the chaos that is racking the nation
president trump's response to all of
this
first as part of our daily wire audience
there are a number of ways that you
can take in the podcast and bathe in it
you could listen on apple podcast
spotify or another podcast app
you may also watch our podcast on
youtube facebook or over at
dailywire.com bottom line we're making
our content available to you
anywhere you watch or listen and now
we're introducing a new upgraded
experience
daily wire is now on apple tv and roku
so members can enjoy
all of the visual elements on this
podcast on your big screen either live
or on demand you can see every
magnificent pour of this beautiful face
find the daily wire on apple tv or roku
and download it today
you have to be an insider member to
watch live so head on over to
dailywire.com shapiro and use code
watch at checkout you get 15 off your
membership purchase when you go to
dailywear.com shapiro and use the code
watch
at checkout because i like watches and
also you should watch this deal won't
last long so act fast if you want live
shows on your big screen plus the one of
a kind highly coveted
leftist tears tumblr again that's
dailywire.com
get 15 off with codewatch and download
the daily wire on your apple tv and roku
today
another great announcement for you gang
the ben shapiro show sunday special
is back all new episode this week
featuring candace owens we'll be talking
about the 2020 election
george floyd cardi b and tons of other
good stuff so
don't miss out this sunday september 6th
you're listening to the largest
fastest growing conservative podcast and
radio show on the nation
alrighty so president trump has
responded to joe biden
uh in a variety of ways so on on monday
afternoon uh he
he suggested on fox news that the
radical left is in control of these
cities joe biden keeps saying this is
trump's america
weird because everybody in these cities
is blue here is donald trump going off
on the radical left
if it weren't donald trump's america to
just use the expression as
i'm president you would have
riots like you've never seen the the
democrats have lost control of the
radical left
and if you look at bernie and the i call
it the manifesto that was agreed to with
biden and his group
that's further left than bernie ever was
they won't be able to control these
people these
people have lot they have lost control
of these people
okay that is absolutely true and then
trump went on he said blm is a marxist
organization now it is incredible how
the media continue to deny this is the
case
of course the organization called black
lives matter which was at the root of
this originally right they were the most
organized group on the ground
and they were the ones who organized the
protest they are an overtly marxist
organization
they literally claim that they are
marxist but apparently if you mention
this this is bad this is sort of like
when you say
that riding and looting is bad and we
should use federal force and then
the media and the democrats they're like
you're talking about protests like no
i'm not talking about protesters
when trump says black lives matter is a
marxist organization it doesn't mean
that every single person who has marched
with blm as a marxist he means the
organization is legit marxist
because they are here was trump
yesterday black lives matter is a
marxist organization
you remember pigs in a blanket fry them
like bacon that was the first time i
ever heard of black lives matter
i said that's a terrible name it's so
discriminatory it's bad for black people
it's bad for everybody
and all of a sudden it becomes like sort
of although now if you look it's going
way down because people are tired of
this stuff what's going on
the black lives matter if you look at
what's going on with the bats and the
they're a lot of thugs okay well again
fact check true
i mean watching what's happening in the
major cities and they are black lives
matter associated
hey show me the lie okay and then trump
went on he said you know joe biden he's
getting credit for
you know condemning violence and writing
and looting the only people that he
blamed here were not the agitators and
the looters right he literally said
he literally said that we need a racial
reckoning and that it's my inability
to this trump it's my inability to speak
with the with the racial agitators that
is causing
all of this and then you blame the cops
right so
trump correctly tweeted just watch what
biden had to say to me he's blaming the
police far more than he's blaming the
writers and our cause agitators and
looters which he could never blame or he
would lose the radical left bernie
supporters
again fact check troop then trump
continued he said biden can't calm this
stuff down because in fact he is a
puppet
which again you can't argue with this
because it's true
biden just like nancy pelosi i'm old
enough to remember when nancy pelosi
suggested
i i keep using the freshman old enough
remember because again it ironically
underscores the fact that democrats are
changing their positions on everything
moderate to
everything radical within 30 seconds
nancy pelosi was very much opposed
to the radicalism and anti-semitism of
some members of the squad until she
decided to water down a resolution and
then back them
in their primary races joe biden is
exactly like nancy pelosi here's trump
saying biden can't calm this stuff down
because
he's not the one in charge biden won't
calm things down
they will take over they will have one
if biden gets in
they will have one he's a weak person
he's controlled like a puppet
so it's not going to be calm things down
it's going to be they will have won they
will have taken over
your cities it's a revolution you
understand that it's a revolution
and the people of this country will not
stand for that
okay then the media chimed in
so the media want answers from trump
they want answers on a couple of
subjects particularly
both are subjects where trump really
should not be sounding off one the media
want trump to sign off on kyle written
house that is a case under investigation
the best possible evidence at this point
including videotape and witness evidence
suggests the kyle written house shot
three people in self-defense
all three people that he shot had
significant long criminal records they
were outside agitators who were inside
kenosha
okay kaylee mcinney the white house
press secretary was asked
about the written house case and whether
and trump's opinion on it and here was
her answer
the president condemned the actions of
kyle rittenhouse who
is accused of shooting some of the
protesters the president
is not going to again weigh in on that
you can ask him this evening he may
weigh in further but at the moment
he's not way into that okay well that
would have been the correct response
then trump was asked and trump of course
immediately steps all over that because
he says well it looks to me like
self-defense now accurate should he be
sounding off on
legitimate law enforcement cases no what
he should be saying at this point
is there's an investigation underway i'm
not going to sound off on an ongoing
investigation
which by the way is what every president
should say under any ongoing
investigation
barack obama also had this unfortunate
habit of jumping into cases
where he didn't have the evidence and
just sounding off on them and
this is the part of the modern
presidency i probably like the least
i even agree with what trump is saying
here on the merits i just think that
it's a bad
look for the president of the united
states to be sounding off on ongoing law
enforcement investigations here with
trump yesterday
that was an interesting situation you
saw the same tape as i saw
and he was trying to get away from them
i guess it looks like
and he fell and then they very violently
attacked him
and it was something that we're looking
at right now and it's under
investigation but
uh i i guess he was in
very big trouble he would have been he
probably would have been killed but
it's under it's under investigation so
people are like he's defending kyle
right now so first of all
his description of the video is so much
more accurate than anything the media
are putting out
okay what the media are putting out
there is the kyle written house they
tried to call him a white nationalist
and then they suggested that he went
there looking to kill okay so
let me give you an example msnbc there's
an analyst named john heilemann
he literally last night on msnbc called
the written house a domestic terrorist
with intent to murder this is the thing
here was john highland yesterday
the core part of that story is a white
trump supporting maga loving uh
blue lives matter social media uh
partisan 17 years old picks up a gun
drives from one state to another with
the intent to shoot people
it might at least make some of them
think okay donald trump has not
completely lost it
this is not a totally grotesque inhuman
force in the white house
at least he's acknowledging that it's
terrible that a black man got shot in
the back seven times
and it's not good that a 17 year old
vigilante
arguably a domestic terrorist picked up
a rifle drove to a different state to
shoot people
okay now the other topic that the media
definitely wanted trump to comment on
is whether he was going to meet with
jacob lake's family let me make this
clear
no president of the united states should
ever meet with the family of a man
who was shot by police while trying to
resist arrest for an open domestic
violence and sexual assault warrant
after being called to the home of a
woman who reported that he raped her
i do not think that merits of
presidential visit do you
i'm confused so if you
rape somebody you allegedly rape
somebody you resist arrest
you go for a weapon in your car by the
available evidence and you get shot
the president is supposed to go to your
family's house
and talk to them about how to run the
country i feel like we have some
elements here that are not quite lining
up
i don't i don't feel like by the way
that should be the response from the
white house like usually kaylee
mackinnaney is very very aggressive
she's a lot more soft spoken on this
question than i would have been here was
kaylee mcinning yesterday
does the president have any plans
currently to meet with jacob blake's
family
currently the plans are to meet with
local law enforcement um and some
business owners and he'll survey the
damage but there will be more detailed
plans forthcoming that are announced
okay so no they should not meet and then
trump was asked about it and he said
that he's not meeting because
they wanted their their attorneys
present and all of this by the way the
attorney benjamin crump
who is always first on the scene
whenever there is a
shooting that involves a white officer
and a black person or anything remotely
like it
and then we'll just mimic lies i mean
benjamin crump went out there and he
originally said
that jacob blake was trying to break up
a fight between two women there's no
evidence this is true right he said that
he was trying he was a good samaritan
and then he tried to walk away from the
cops and none of that ended up being
true
but here is president trump trying to
make an excuse for not meeting with
blake what he should say is
i typically don't meet with the families
of people who are alleged rapists who
then get shot by the police
in the process of attempting to resist
arrest by all available evidence
that's he if he wants to go a little
softer he could just say i don't meet
with the families of people who are
under active criminal investigation
could do that too
right but instead we get this this kind
of soft stuff
spoke with the pastor wonderful man the
family's pastor
and i thought it would be better not to
do anything with their lawyers involved
they wanted me to speak but they wanted
to have lawyers involved and i thought
that was inappropriate so i didn't do
that
but i did speak with the pastor of the
family it was a
fine man a wonderful man and i think we
had a great talk and
uh i may at some point you know do that
okay he shouldn't he shouldn't go talk
to jacob blake's family any more than
michael brown's family she's been put
at the forefront of the blm movement and
the blm movement has a very bad habit of
picking
actual criminals to defend who who
attack police officers who resist arrest
who commit actual crimes
uh which suggests that really it has
nothing to do with the facts on the
ground it has to do with
with purveying a narrative okay then
trump didn't interview with laura ingram
last night and in his interview
he had some rather controversial
statements some good some bad because
with trump
you always have to take the good along
with the bad
so here are some of the bad trump
suggested that the officer in the blake
case
it was like missing a putt it was like
people choke it was like missing a putt
no
again this was probably a legally
justified shoot by all available
evidence
but here is trump comparing it to a
missed golf but i mean like this is not
useful in any way
they choke just like in a golf
tournament
they miss a three foot you're not
comparing it to golf because of course
that's what the media
i'm saying people choke people people
choke
and people are bad people yeah both you
have some bad people and you have
they choke you could be a police officer
for 15 years and all of a sudden you're
confronted
you've got a quarter of a second to make
a decision
if you don't make the decision and
you're wrong you're dead
people choke under those circumstances
trump was also asked by members of the
media about
people who were who are in portland and
who were using paintballs on
antifa protesters now he is correct here
he says they were firing paintballs they
weren't firing bullets
and also what he should have mentioned
is the reason they were firing
paintballs and mace at people is because
those people were actively attempting to
block their trucks
and do them violent and here's president
trump saying that paint isn't the same
as bullets
they had large numbers of people that
were supporters but that was a peaceful
protest
and paint is not and paint as a
defensive mechanism paint is not bullets
your supporters your supporters and they
are your supporters indeed
shot a young gentleman
who and killed him not with paint
but with a bullet and i think it's
disgraceful
okay he is right about that okay he is
right about that by the way it is also
true that trump
did in fact say that he does not want
his supporters acting like law
enforcement
like he did say that you know the media
is going to ignore that but he
he did say it he hears trump saying it
do you want your supporters to confront
the left-wing protesters or do you want
to leave it to law no i don't want them
i want to leave it to law enforcement
but
my supporters are wonderful hard-working
tremendous people
and they turn on their television set
and they look at a portland or they look
at a kenosha before i got involved and
stopped it
they're looking at all of this and they
can't believe it
they can't believe it whether it's my
supporter or not but you don't want them
showing you no i don't well it's a
peaceful protest i mean they were
protesting
okay again he is he's not wrong
about all of this okay meanwhile
president trump is slated to go to
kenosha wisconsin today to talk
members of the local democratic party
are very upset about it they're members
of the kenosha
city council some of whom are
republicans are very excited about it
trump explained last night the reason
that he is going to kenosha he says i'm
going there to thank law enforcement
by the way not inappropriate considering
the law enforcement is in fact under
assault in kenosha
here was president trump explaining why
is it
important for you to be seen by the
people of wisconsin now
because i am a tremendous fan of law
enforcement
and i want to thank the law enforcement
they've done a good job and when the
governor says
that i shouldn't come or he'd prefer
that i not come
i'm the one that called him and said
tony you got to bring out the national
guard well i don't really want to do it
tony you got to bring it out
and unlike your governor of oregon that
just keeps saying no
he agreed to it at least okay so it is
not inappropriate for the president to
go out there and defend the police
because
joe biden is assaulting the police in
his in his verbiage i mean there's no
question his entire speech yesterday was
predicated on the notion that the cops
are the bad guys
meanwhile the cops are again under
assault
all over the united states an lapd
station in van nuys was vandalized and
an american flag set on fire last night
well actually that was over the weekend
several protesters according to
foxnews.com
vandalized an lapd station friday night
set an american flag on fire
about 50 protesters gathered in los
angeles van nuys neighborhood around 11
p.m wearing masks and dark colored
clothing
and then spray paints at the elevator
saying you're all going to lose pigs
good times portland more riots last
night in portland antifa rioters smashed
up businesses a riot was declared for
what the 90th 93rd 94th straight night
over in portland here's a little bit of
that video
[Music]
ironically mayor ted wheeler who has
spent the last several months
pretending that the rioters don't exist
and the looters are his friends uh he
was
victimized by them sitting outside his
condo and firing fireworks directly
outside his condo
so it was not an honor of his birthday
it was in honor of them thinking that
he's a stupid idiot because he is in
fact a stupid idiot
[Music]
okay meanwhile there was uh there
there's
more happening over the weekend there's
a mob chanting death to america so
adopting this sort of language from iran
which is great in oakland on sunday
night all of this seems like this is
going really well and joe biden
condemning white nationalists will
probably solve it here is
here is the footage from oakland on
sunday night
i feel like that we should just bring
them to the table all we have to do to
bring these folks to the table
is presumably mouth some slogans about
systemic racism
in the united states probably that's
that's the solution
we can expect that there will be some
violence tonight in los angeles
after all protesters began to gather
after la sheriff's deputies shot a black
man during a confrontation
um he punched a police officer and also
had a handgun by the way i know that
that's a sub headline
but we are we are supposed to pretend
that the only thing that matters is the
color of the people as opposed to the
activity of the people
according to abc news protesters
gathered in south la monday night
after a los angeles sheriff's deputy
shot and killed a black man who they say
had a handgun and was fighting with them
the shooting occurred monday afternoon
after two deputies pulled over a man who
was riding a bicycle in violation of
vehicle laws
according to sheriff's department
lieutenant brandon dean the man then got
off the bike and ran off
and deputies ran him down because when
you resist arrest they'll run you down
right you know when you get pulled over
for a bicycle violation probably should
just take the ticket
according to dean our suspect was
holding some items of clothing in his
hands
punched one of the officers in the face
and then dropped the items in his hands
the deputies noticed that inside the
clothing items he dropped was a black
semi-automatic handgun
at which time a deputy-involved shooting
occurred the suspect was struck several
times both officers fired their weapons
deputies recovered the handgun the man
had been carrying the investigation is
currently
ongoing and black lives matter la
started protest last night thank god
they remained
mostly peaceful and i say mostly
peaceful i didn't see any elements of
violence
didn't stop racial agitators like tariq
nasheed online from trying to claim that
certain
incidents were in fact acts of violence
that were connected with
all of this they they were not there was
there's a car that was driven into a
shoe store
i had on melrose it had literally
nothing to do with this as far as we are
aware
uh it was unconnected to didn't stop
tariq nasheed from tweeting that out
also tariq nasheed tweeted out
that white hispanic i'm not kidding you
white hispanic
was responsible for the shooting white
hispanic
basically now anybody who's bad can be
categorized as white
and the the the police officer in this
case was in fact hispanic but apparently
he's a white hispanic because everybody
who is bad is white according to the
racial radicals now
you can tell why all this is happening
the reason that all this is happening
and the reason that the biden campaign
is responding is because they are
concerned that there's going to be
movement in the polls in fact there's an
emerson poll out today
that shows biden up just two points
people are treating this as an outlier
pole but emerson is in fact a good
polling outfit
that is a wildly disparate pull from the
morning console poll that came out
showing biden still up eight nationally
and
up large in every major swing state
which poll do you believe
well i mean i tend to believe the poll
that shows the tightening of the race
because historically after conventions
things tighten and two because i think
everybody has the gut level feeling that
the riots and the violence in america's
major cities
are not going to play well for the
democrats in fact the washington post
phillip rucker
is openly admitting that the biden
campaign is concerned that around
detroit there are a bunch of blue lives
matter signs that have been going up
here is philip rucker yesterday
there is concern there that these images
and that this law and order message from
the president
is working to start to pry away some of
those white voters
i was talking to uh congresswoman debbie
dingle
the other day she represents a suburban
detroit district and she said she drives
around her district and she has seen a
lot of blue lives matter
signs popping up in suburban
neighborhoods and that has given her
serious pause
and she's been communicating that with
the biden campaign okay well it should
be giving them serious pause and there's
a reason that joe biden
basically stayed in the basement until
he had to jet to pennsylvania for
five seconds the media have come up with
a bunch of alternative explanations for
what's happening
and their alternative explanations range
from the bizarre
to the plainly insulting to the
intelligence
daniel dale who's the supposed
fact-checker over at cnn who's a radical
lefty
uh daniel dale he suggested this is his
fact check on antifa
he suggested that antifa is quote a
loose collection of anti-fascists
so here he is i mean that that amounts
to effectively a defense of antifa
they're not anti-fascists they are in
fact fascists who are doing mob violence
to people
in the streets but here is fact checker
from cnn an apple is an apple and a
banana is a banana except when a banana
is an apple here's daniel dale
he also said that biden's speech today
was strange and he specifically
criticized him for
not naming antifa it's true that biden
didn't mention antifa this
loose collection of anti-fascists but
biden issued a broad condemnation of
violence rioting looting
of all kinds so yes he didn't say that
word but it's not like he carved out
some sort of exemption
for antifa this was a broad base
combination of antifa like tactics
that's unbelievable i mean that is such
unbelievable water carrying for the
biden campaign so it's true he didn't
mention antifa but he did condemn
violence across the board i look forward
to all such statements being treated
this way going back in time to
charlottesville
all broad statements condemning bad
things happening are now sufficient
apparently
for everyone in the media unless you're
republican in which case you have to be
extremely specific about who it is
you're calling out
because there's the excuse making by the
media and then there are members of the
media who just say bizarre
incredible conspiracy theories so angela
rye on cnn who can always be counted on
for a bizarre conspiracy theory
she says that what's actually happening
in these riots and looting
are infiltrators trying to discredit the
movement oh
oh it's all infiltrators is it right so
it is true they're outside agitators who
are going into kenosha and making
trouble
it is also true that we saw broad
spontaneous riots and looting in
virtually every major american city
springing directly from blm protests
okay but apparently it is all outside
agitators maybe white supremacists or
something who are going undercover
here's angela rye promoting this
conspiracy theory call out the president
and make him condemn that violence
and not talk about these fringe uh
people
who are out here wearing the banner and
acting as if they're affiliated with
black lives matter but are in fact
not affiliated at all i'm willing to bet
you
over and over again that those folks
have no affiliation
with the actual movement and they are
just a part of what we have seen
historically in this country and that is
infiltrators designed to undermine the
desired need and the firm pursuit
of justice oh so that's what it is it's
probably a bunch of secret right-wingers
who are attempting to discredit the
movement
that's a theory except for how we've
been showing footage for the past
several weeks of actual black lives
matter spokespeople calling openly for
violence
throughout the united states so there's
that meanwhile cnn's april ryan who can
always be counted on
for some good reporting april ryan who
is a political analyst for
cnn she suggests that trump is
instigating a race war
trump is instigating a race war uh-huh
here she was last night on cnn this
president donald john trump
has instigated a race war in america
portland oregon is ground zero
this president donald john trump
has basically stoked the flames for
racist extremists neo-nazis
and the alt-right people are now afraid
of this president
because he has stoked the racial flames
and let's call the thing a thing
he has now begun a race war in america
in 2020.
trump has begun a race war in america in
2020 really was it him
because it seems to me that the people
who have been stoking the racial flames
for years on end are people who claim
that the entire system of america
is racist that you're either racist or
an anti-racist
one of the things that was amazing about
biden's speech yesterday is biden did
this routine where he said most police
officers are good
we like most police officers and i
pointed out that means absolutely
nothing
when you suggest that the police are
systemically racist because
when you say systemically racist what
you mean is that the entire system of
policing is racist
which means that you're either complicit
in that system or you're anti the system
right this is ibrahim kennedy's model of
thinking you're either racist
or you're anti-racist so it doesn't
matter if you're a good person and a
nice person
if you're complicit in a system of
racism you are in fact one of the
operators of the racist system
so who's who exactly has started the ra
the ra who's maintaining the racial
conflict here
who is stoking racial conflict who's
stoking a race war here
donald trump i love how she uses
portland as an example of this in
portland it's white people fighting
white people
it is really not black lives matter in
portland it's black lives matter in
kenosha
it's black lives matter in in chicago
and l.a and new york and you see it is
not black lives matter
in portland it's a bunch of white people
so this
ground zero in the race war is a bunch
of white people shooting at each other
in in portland
and really one side shooting the other
in portland but this is the the new
narrative the new narrative pushed by
dana milbank over at the washington post
is that trump is trying to foment a race
war he's trying to foment a race war
he says when the president's supporters
often armed drive into cities to provoke
racial justice demonstrators oh it's
provocation now if you take over major
american cities like portland
and you take them over full scale and
you do violence every night that is not
a provocation
it's that people are driving with
american flags on their truck what a
provocation
you mean you took advantage of america's
free speech rights to drive a truck with
an american flag
into a major american city obviously
obviously provocative
obviously your fault trump calls them
great patriots his convention glorified
vigilantes who took up arms against
protesters disgraceful anarchists and
thugs and trump's telling
are you talking specifically about the
mccloskeys you know the family who like
stood on their porch because people were
threatening them with violence after
breaking into a private gated community
dana milbank
the president declares the backlash
against demonstrators by his supporters
cannot be unexpected and says the only
way you will stop violence in high crime
democrat cities
is through strength again none of that's
racial
he proposes that the far-right militia
member who allegedly killed two
protesters in wisconsin
acted in self-defense fact check he
probably did act in self-defense
how's that stoking a racial war but
again this is the media narrative
it's a media narrative that is backed by
the biden campaign the media and the
biden campaign are completely
inseparable at this point that is
perfectly obvious
and you should be aware of this when you
watch the media coverage of everything
that comes next
alrighty we'll be back here later today
with two additional hours of content
you're listening to the ben shapiro show
the ben shapiro show is produced by
colton haas our technical director is
austin stevens
executive producer jeremy boring our
supervising producers are mathis glover
and robert sterling
assistant director pava wydowsky our
associate producer is nick chien
the show is edited by adam scievent
audio mix by mike caromina hair and
makeup is by nico geneva
the ben shapiro show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire 20 20.
hey everybody it's andrew clavin host of
the andrew clavin show you know some
people are depressed because the
american republic is collapsing the end
of days is approaching
and the moon has turned to blood but on
the andrew clavin show that's where the
fun just gets started
so come on over to the andrew clavin
show and laugh your way through the
apocalypse with me
andrew clinton